my name is Elena Taran I'm a press
officer at the falling walls foundation
and I take care of the press work for
the Berlin science week I have a very
versatile background I started studied
Linguistics English philology politics
and communication and journalism that's
how I basically ended up here
um it's going to be my third science
week already and I remember what what
motivated me before just the pure scope
of well the topics and the scientists
and the research and just to get in
touch with all those people and of
course us bringing the message out how
important science is and how ubiquitous
it actually is and that it influences
all of our lives
we always want to see all of those 200
sessions and to be everywhere and all
those 10 days but you really have to
choose so yeah that's the the best and
the worst part I guess but I'm really
looking forward to all of the topics
that we're going to do this year again